Donald Trump is now calling the FBI
quote truly a cancer in our country when
I read it I actually thought you know
Richard Nixon probably felt the same way
towards the end there he probably would
would have had a similar point of view
about the FBI the FBI is not an
objectively perfect or even delightful
organization there's this really sort of
complex dynamic that's developed where
merely by defending the fact that the
Trump Russia investigation makes sense
you have some on the Left attacked four
haphazardly supporting such a dark
institution as the FBI or the CIA and
supporting every bad thing that every
Intelligence Agency has ever done so
let's start at the obvious the FBI is
not objectively great as an organization
it is an intelligence security and law
enforcement agency it's part of the
apparatus of so-called Justice in the
United States it's run by people people
make mistakes
it has scandals it makes errors it's not
infallible so what I'm trying to say but
its mere existence in and of itself
isn't the problem
much like the existence of the House of
Representatives isn't the problem the
problem is that much of the House of
Representatives has been overrun by
right-wing ideological lunatics so the
FBI is the FBI and allowing the right to
frame the FBI at a sort of institutional
level as the problem is problematic and
allowing the left to be framed as blind
haphazard defenders of the FBI is also a
problem because the FBI has done bad
things so that gets us to this week
Donald Trump did an interview with the
hill TV Hill dot Hill dot TV I guess it
is Donald Trump said during that
interview that the FBI's quote truly a
cancer in our country he's framing the
existence of the FBI and what it has
done simply by carrying out its duties
to be some kind of dereliction of their
actual duties and during this interview
Donald Trump presents what is really an
alternative reality in terms of what the
FBI is doing or should be doing Trump
said this was all related to trump
russia trump said during this interview
that the trump russia investigation is
quote one of the great scandals in the
history of our country using some of the
same language that we've heard from
trump before and we've sort of become
accustomed to Trump said it's a hoax
beyond a witch-hunt
Trump said during the same interview
with the hill TV Comey was a bad guy I
actually think that the broader attacks
on the FBI are nothing more than a
distraction because they like to say you
know the FBI did bad things look at what
the FBI did under Hoover the FBI tried
to get Martin Luther King to commit
suicide these are fair criticisms right
Police Department do bad things
militaries do bad things but to use that
as the explanation for why the Trump
Russia investigation is bad is a version
of the of the genetic ad hominem fallacy
right the FB i--'s Trump Russia
investigation is bad because the FBI
once tried to get Martin Luther King to
kill himself oxygen is bad because
Hitler also breathed oxygen right now
the FBI is investigating real dangers to
American democracy you can say American
democracy is broken I'm with you but the
investigation is in two very real things
Russia does this they try to undermine
democracy all over the world they did
the same thing in the United States the
only real check we have right now is the
judiciary and investigations like this
one that are being carried out that by
the FBI this doesn't mean that the FBI
is beyond scrutiny this doesn't mean
that the FBI and the CIA and our
military all of these institutions have
done bad things in the past but the
problem isn't the FBI as an entity which
is the problem that Republicans claim to
have and by the way if you need more
proof of that Republicans seemed fine
with the FBI when it was investigating
Hillary Clinton it was fine when James
Comey made the decision to come out and
say oh you know what we are gonna take
just another look into the Hillary
Clinton
stuff days before the November 2016
election they're not at odds with the
FBI pat they're at odds with this
investigation and Trump is trying to
make it seem as though the FBI
institutionally is the problem yeah and
certainly Trump would have more
credibility if all along throughout his
entire life he was anti FBI like if he
called out the atrocities under J Edgar
Hoover or their Martin Luther King
situation no he kept quiet about it his
entire life only now that they're
investigating him is he outraged about
it you you think trumps keyed in on the
issue of MLK and the FBI or the nuances
of what happened under J Edgar Hoover
you think that that's an area of
expertise for on MLK did so many great
things and people now are starting to
pay attention to it only now right
exactly we're only now figuring out what
happened then so this is I and I know
that most people in the audience don't
need to be told this like I get that
most people in our audience understand
that the criticisms of the FBI are
number one not actually criticisms of
this investigation like a lot of us on
the Left have been criticizing these
institutions for a very long time but
that doesn't mean that every single
thing they do needs to be stopped or is
problematic so I know that a lot of
people in our audience don't need to be
sort of given that speech but the double
standard with which all of a sudden
systemically the FBI is the problem is
the truly laughable part what do you
think about this I hope that you are
following the david pakman show on
instagram at david pakman show where we
will frequently have polls about issues
that come up on the show like what's
your opinion about the FBI and lots of
behind the scenes pictures and much more
follow the david pakman show on
instagram at david pakman show you can
also follow me at david pakman check out
pictures from my recent trip and much
much more
we will take a break and come back we're
going to talk about productivity but
it's not just going to be here's how
many cups of coffee a day you should
have that is Pat's doing a special about
that some other day
and we'll hear all about his coffee
drinking habits that's not what the
interview is about though it will be
about productivity as a sort of
institution that is now becoming
popularized in the United States quick
break back after this this episode is
sponsored in part by better help calm
Pakman which gives you access to a fully
licensed and experienced psychologist or
therapist through videophone and text I
know from the emails I get that in our
audience like in the broader world there
are people who are struggling with
different issues in their lives and many
of them choose not to talk to somebody
about it either for financial reasons
for reasons of stigma associated with
seeking out a therapist and I think it's
really important to do everything you
can to get past that because it's really
important to talk to someone when you
feel like that's the right thing to do
and what better help calm provides is
number one the elimination of the stigma
that could be associated with it you
work through video phone whichever
method is best for you you also will be
able to save money compared to seeing an
in-person therapist and it is so easy to
get started that I encourage you to go
to better help calm slash Pakman a few
questions that you answer which will get
you paired up with a therapist that
meets your needs you can always switch
to somebody else if you don't feel as
though the match is a good fit and it is
something that everybody should have
access to go to better help calm slash
Pakman it's easy to sign up it's easy to
get started we've put a link in the
description if you're watching on
YouTube and once again that website is
better help calm /pa k ma n